hello and welcome to this video playing
R&B 06 11 jun many many high rated
players that I just don't know okay so
I've the scotch and play my my special
variation may again even though I really
don't score all that well with it I have
to really find something else am I think
or refresh whatever what I'm knowing
okay this line is very inoffensive that
he is playing here but still let's see
okay d5 I think that's Bishop g5 this is
not not that clear I wanted to go d5 of
course but now now I saw Bishop g5 I'm
not so sure about it anymore h6 sf4
chan g5 Bishop g5 hmm strange strange
but it seems good anyway any other move
doesn't make sense at all by now he has
figured Bishop g5 order also I think No
ok so here interesting stuff maybe just
maybe just to see form Jan complicated
if I've is not clear to me and you can
go to f2 of course and has to go to
actual good now that could be good for
white the seaport is probably probably a
weakness here you know ok trying for
some come to play you with age four
you
maybe actually taking and b5 as an idea
I should have thought about this for a
moment at least it looks bad on the dark
squares but it would make sure that my
knight on d5 is staying I should have
thought about this now the c-4 point is
gone I mean this is not completely
uninteresting it's just that I should
have thought about this this other
option definitely would have been would
have been interesting okay so here 97a
to f5 maybe Jim doesn't look all that
attractive
we should be 60 we'll just move the
Queen a question is where maybe I can
take on before then and then block on
the light squares a queen d7 probably
just King h2 anyway I have to get get
going here yeah but you can tick with
the Queen I should have played that the
other variation that wasn't clear at all
I think at least okay
see for probably
yeah taking on age three and doesn't
really threaten much can probably play C
for him
see from Jack came just taking it is
also not bad of course that's a very
technical way of playing it unless i'm
totally not spotting the point san was
looking for coming now like d4 takes
Queen d5 maybe I could have done that
anyway here we go check granny would
edge for with made let's made check or
queen h5 thoughts like resides there's a
good game I was completely busted I
think if he plays with c4 didn't didn't
really see anything for me the c-4 is
just trying I think I didn't see a move
here to ask energies on what 2.7 yeah
that was it was just losing for me check
I mean this is also good for white but
the way he played it with the taking I
could have played Queen f5 here already
with the advantage and this is now
getting difficult check ok King age 3 is
is helping me of course tremendously
King edge to seems to be a draw
according to the computer
Jim this is now he has to nice now it's
lost already King h2 is also losing
Kashuk and then this cool I don't know
if I would have found that i have to say
don't quite get it actually those of
this check check this is winning amazing
check check check yeah edwins funny and
I wasn't lucky win really lucky win I
made a made a big mistake I'm with age 5
I think here I should probably consider
to take this Bishop takes b5 and at
least i have this night now anchored
it's probably still bad it's the last GF
y 5 now I probably this isn't so great
in the first place hmm therefore was an
interesting move really 93 years the
engine move instead of night c4 I don't
know that g3 setup is usually not not
very dangerous but maybe I have to play
in an in a more restrained fashion like
like this so what the computer
recommends that was very lucky win
thanks for watching